Whitney and I have had a pretty rough go
filming season three it hasn't been easy
but nothing heals wounds faster than a
girls trip you guys Carmen San Diego
you've been worried about her she's here
oh my gosh I'm hoping all the women are
gonna love that I'm their biggest fan
and I'm hoping that they'll Overlook the
fact that I kind of bring the Glam
Factor down and so I'm gonna make up for
it with like a lot of jokes I'm just
thrilled
be here could I have a million questions
to answer the Gen show of it all yeah so
Whitney Whitney just gets a pure pass on
this one well she said you were with her
no I ride for Jen for sure I am
processing it like right now live that's
what we want to know what happened
because she told you that she was
innocent well she told me she was
innocent for a year and she swore on her
family's lives sure on their lives that
she was innocent that these were both
charges
I haven't done anything and my family
doesn't
deserve I'm calling in
my innocence
but you knew she was lying listen uh I I
don't know the truth is we are texting
but we have not got had a real
conversation yet and I don't know what
changed you know what it is 30 years
when you're facing 30 years in a second
you're like I'm pleading to 14. I mean I
don't know she called me five minutes
before she walked into the courtroom and
said I don't want you to be blindsided
Jen's almost your manipulator it's very
easy for her to lie and to put on this
like
facade that you get so confused because
you don't know who the real Jen is I
just cried with her I just cried with
her on the phone because she believed
she was innocent
I don't know
she either lied to me five minutes
before she went into the courtroom where
she lied to the judge were you friends
with Jen before the show yes and I ride
for her heart I still do just
yourself I mean yes she did loyalty is
great but when you realize that you're
loyal to the wrong person you got to
know when to retreat back it up abort
Whitney got zero questions I've
come to time
together Jasmine how do you feel about
like not being even allowed to like put
your bags down before the grilling
starts I expected it and I'm glad that
somebody thinks I have something to say
just don't ignore me yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah because it's just I'm in it too I
know but like you're you're someone who
I feel like it's probably been
manipulated by a narcissist okay
foreign